[Music]
akali has terrorized summoner's rift for
over a decade
[Music]
nin goes in finally gets one but
showmaker gets an instant reply now the
shy gets blown up by show maker who is
putting on a show rookie has no mana
truffle for show maker
she's meant to be broken if you're good
and useless if you suck
fantastic grand entrance to come through
but the callisto already taken down can
they still win the fight as a question
of course the answer from lava is
absolutely yes it's a quadra kill can it
be the fencer for lava back-to-back
games with a phenomenal performance and
yes they will be able to give it to him
the celebration as that's the pentakill
in our first match
but when riot buffs are like every new
champion they release it ruins the skill
cap of the game
some champs get nerfed so hard that they
never see play again but somehow akali
survived
[Music]
question
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to make sure that
you're all sub to the channel and if you
aren't subbed already please hit the
subscribe button and turn on
notifications it really does help anyway
for a lot of players akali has always
been broken but that's not exactly
telling the whole story she was released
back in season 1 on may 11 2010 as one
of the first assassins in the game she
was designed as a high skill champion
who could suddenly ambush opponents and
kill them quickly if she messed up she
died rewarding only the best players and
the ability that truly emphasized that
was her alt shadow dance it was one of
the only long range movement abilities
in the game at the time which made her
one of the flashiest characters to play
yeah duke she's going wow wow
that is wes rice on his game right there
you can hear the crowd loving every
second of it alistar however right on
his heels there comes the clairvoyance
oh able to dodge past again once the
initial hype died down though akali ran
into some problems her pick rate and
rank plummeted to only four percent
worldwide and with a win rate of only 45
in june 2011 riot needed to do something
to keep one of league's original
assassins in the mix the biggest area of
concern was akali's twilight shroud
ability see it was intended to allow you
to outplay opponents and get out of
sticky situations the problem was the
twilight shroud was rendered completely
useless the second anyone put a pink
ward near it ryan spent the next couple
of years buffing akali her passive was
now always active without the use of any
runes or masteries and while a trout
provided vision wherever it was placed
around the same time pink wards were
nerfed which only helped buffakali even
more unfortunate for quas oh boy
boy boy going in on man cloud that is a
scenario of
a long time champion being played new
new there's the assault battery coming
in the ball breaker can still pop him up
but wow boy boy is just getting fed
right now after these changes some pros
began picking the newly buffed akali and
at worlds 2014 the eventual winners
samsung white showed everyone just how
strong she'd become he's trying to find
what he can death gets hit up there's no
appeal for him chain of corruption did
go out but as soon as looper is led out
of that prison he is just knocking down
the walls and finding more kills a
double for him another ace for samsung
white going into season five people were
worried that akali was no longer an
assassin that rewarded good mechanics
instead it seemed like she was
overpowered and way too easy to play so
riot decided to nerf her but they didn't
just nerf her
they killed her
[Music]
patch 5.2 removed the bonus damage from
a crescent slash and mark of the
assassin combo and reduced the range of
her alt after these changes both her
pick rate and win rate tanked and almost
overnight akali became irrelevant over
the next couple of years riot tried
tweaking her over and over but they just
couldn't seem to get it right they even
changed some of her core abilities but
still outside of dedicated akali maines
nobody really cared to play her the
problem was that plenty of stronger
flashier assassins had come out since
rakali was first released so riot had to
do something big to make her relevant
again which is why she got a huge rework
in 2018. what'd i tell you eight dashes
true i i called it go find go find the
vaude i called it true invisibility i
said that
and a million dashes with insane bursts
what i say i told you
stupid [ __ ] players were excited and
optimistic that akali might finally be a
viable pick again but when she hit the
pbe server in july 2018 some players
like ls voice their concerns i mean her
kit is busted i think the q looks overly
busted the w looks overly busted have to
know exactly what the ratios are for the
the r and the e passive looks nuts as
well it just seems like we're getting
another aurelia very very very soon she
was quickly picked up by everybody in
solo queue but when she finally made her
appearance in pro play that's when
things got really out of hand
a little bit of what you expect as finn
tries to push away jenkins gets the
stealth under the turret stays alive at
120 hp holds in oh
my
word akali was one of league's long
forgotten original champions but now she
was just as broken as some of riot's
recent releases because he's going 1v4
lava is going to be the first one to go
down
he's going to be tagged up but no
backflip going to be reactivated anchovy
the two-for-nothing one before it seemed
that every new champion terrorized the
game the moment they launched and since
akali was always meant to be the kind of
hard-to-play champion you worked your
way up to it kind of ruined the point if
you could just pick her up and get a
free penta under tower if ig tries to
continue the fight they are going to be
four versus five but the shot
no way
and even though she was completely
busted riot continued to push their
beloved assassin on everyone
kda became increasingly popular when the
skins launched in the game akali was
more than just a league of legends
champion now she was a pop culture icon
but with her immense popularity came
increased scrutiny if every new player
was suddenly popping off on akali it
wasn't going to be great for the game
over time riot slowly started
implementing nerfs to try to balance her
but nothing really seemed to work they
removed the heel from her q her w no
longer kept her safe from turrets and to
top it all off they even removed the
micro stun from her ultimate but despite
all these nerfs she was still being
played by some of the world's best
players because even with some of her
numbers tweaked top players could still
be rewarded for their raw mechanical
skills
killed by perks but jake is taken down
by cajul capps is running a match
there's already killed [ __ ] a sing now
captain's found one he's found two he's
turning cajul manages to kill mickey
everybody's dying but it's captain
wonder they may be able to finish the
swine out cagel is gonna
blown up this should be the game expect
the starting to back away it's up to
caps and wonder to push to expect expect
the man that started to fight the man
that might be standing when the fight is
ended it is all on caps the big roster
move that made g2e sports the super team
no matter what riot did to her macaulay
stayed relevant because she's the
ultimate skill expression champion she's
one of the hardest characters to play at
a high level so after her rework she was
pretty much always viable in the right
hands but the same can be said for most
new or reworked champions nearly all of
them are busted at release get nerfed a
couple of times and maybe even get a
small buff before the next champion
comes out and the cycle repeats but can
we really blame riot sure they receive
plenty of flack for sucking at balancing
league but with 156 champions to choose
from even the smallest change can turn
the game on its head
akali has been a part of the broken
champion rework cycle there were moments
where she was too good and so easy to
play that she no longer rewarded strong
mechanics and then there were times
where she was so underpowered that not
even high level players could make her
work and that's where we're at now at
the beginning of this year riot
basically gave up on akali they nerfed
her so much that she's unplayable it
looks like the balance team is balancing
around pro play and essentially killing
the champion instead of figuring out a
way that works for everyone
very very
interesting
not lazy
great decision making
i got nothing and if things weren't bad
enough they decided to nerf her again in
june since then the unfortunate souls
who call themselves akali maines have
once again been left waiting for the day
when riot gives her the buffs that she
so desperately needs
[Music]
akali has been broken in the past and
will likely be broken again she was an
old champion reinvented and reworked to
keep up with the modern age of league of
legends when her numbers are strong
she's busted and when her numbers are
bad she's unpickable but the whole time
she was built for the best players in
the game akali is meant to be the
champion we aspire to the character who
we dream of one day being good enough to
play whenever she breaks and she becomes
too easy or too weak she reminds us how
delicate this 12 year old game really is
but when she works and the best players
in the world pop off on her she reminds
us that sometimes riot can get it right
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages